right eighteen percent as a decimal and
as a fraction in simplest form so let's
do it as a decimal first so 18 percent
18 percent is the same thing as 18 per
hundred or 18 percent I'm actually
separating out the percent worst won't
be one word but I'm writing is literally
percent cent means the same thing as
hundred so this is literally means 18
per hundred actually I said I would do
the decimal first but we can start
putting it into a fraction first
eighteen per 100 as a fraction literally
means 18 per hundred we're literally
doing so we're doing the fraction first
this literally means 18 per hundred or
18 hundredths now if we want to do it we
could from here we could go straight to
a decimal or we could do this fraction
in simplest form let's do the decimal
first just because that's actually where
I said I would do first so let's do that
first so how do we write so this is the
same thing this is the same thing as 18
hundredths hundredths 18 hundredths and
we know how to write that in decimal
form its 0.18 you could view this as one
tenth and eight hundredths which is the
same thing or 10 hundredths and eight
hundredths which is 18 hundredths so
this is written in decimal form and if
we write it as a simplified fraction we
need to see if there is a common factor
but for 18 and 100 and they're both even
numbers so we know they're both
divisible by two so let's divide both
the numerator and the denominator by two
so we have 18 divided by two over 100
divided by two and we're going to get 18
divided by 2 is 9 100 divided by 2 is 50
and I don't think these guys share any
common factors 50 is not divisible by 3
9 is only divisible by 3 and 1 and 9 so
this is the fraction in simplest form so
we have 18% is the same thing as 0.18
which is the same thing in simplest form
as 950 it's now I went through a lot of
I guess pain here to show you that look
this really just comes from
the word from percent from per hundred
but if you ever were to see this in a
problem the fast way to do this is to
immediately say okay if I have if I have
18% you should immediately say anything
in front of the percent that's that
anything whatever this anything is this
should be equal to that anything in this
case it's 18 over 100 and another way to
think about it
you could view this as 18 point zero
percent so this is 18 point zero percent
when you want to convert this I just
added a trailing zero there if you want
to just so that you see the decimal
really so if you want to express this as
a decimal at without the percent you
just move this over to you move the
decimal to the left two spaces so if we
move the decimal to the left two spaces
one two this becomes 0.18 0.18 or you
could immediately say that look 18
percent as a fraction is 18 over 100
when you put it in simplified form it's
9 over 50 but you should also see that
18 over 100 and we have seen this is the
exact same thing as 18 hundredths or
0.18 hopefully this made some
connections for you and didn't confuse
you